you know if I were writing a screenplay
for a movie called Seven Psychopaths
Christopher Walken would definitely be
on the top list for actors I wanted
Seven Psychopaths is a movie I saw at
TIFF I actually got to see it at The
Midnight Madness these people were
intense for this movie they were
anticipating it the entire cast was
there and the director Seven Psychopaths
is a movie about a screenwriter he's
trying to write a screenplay of that
name and he's trying to figure out who
his Seven Psychopaths are and as he goes
through these situations in the movie he
keeps encountering people he's like that
guy would be good that guy would be good
but there really isn't one distinct plot
that I can say to describe this movie
because it is a constant array of
hilarious amazingly well-written scenes
in which people just sit around and talk
about nothing really it's like Seinfeld
or Pulp Fiction is one of the funniest
movies I've seen all year this is one of
the best movies I've seen in a while it
reminded me so much of Pulp Fiction
I adored this movie this was so so good
like I said Colin Farrell is writing
this screenplay Sam Rockwell is his
friend and him and Christopher Walken
have this thing they're doing where they
kidnapped people's dogs who are rich and
then they return them to them thinking
like oh I found your dog here here's
your dog he was on the side of the
street and I found him and they just
want the reward and so they're just
doing nothing with their life but most
of the movie is them just sitting around
talking about random stuff until they
kidnapped the wrong persons dog that's
Woody Harrelson and this guy is a killer
and he loves his little Shih Tzu I'm
telling you this is probably the best
screenplay of the year right now a
hundred percent completely unpredictable
there's nothing in this movie where I
was about to go yeah this is about to
happen okay that's about to happen yeah
whatever all right the audience I saw it
at TIFF was laughing at everything all
the jokes hit and there is a surprising
amount of gore in this movie and that's
probably why it was at The Midnight
Madness section at if Sam Rockwell in
this movie blew me away this is probably
the best performance I've ever seen from
him actually I really honestly think it
is his best performance he was so funny
in this movie there is no other
performance I've seen him give they can
compare to this it's just he was on
point in this movie just completely on
target now the director of this movie
who made in Bruges also very good this
guy man
is someone to watch this ah I just this
movie was just so good the shots were
extremely well filmed this is also the
best Christopher Walken has been in
years he is fantastic
in this movie I am so glad to see him in
a movie where he's not parroting himself
it's so different it's so hilarious it's
one of my favorite movies of the year I
adored Seven Psychopaths
I loved it loved it loved it it was just
so funny Seven Psychopaths gets an A if
you get a chance to see when it comes
out do not miss this movie it's one of
the best of the year it's my favorite
screenplay of the year it's actually my
favorite comedy of the year it's dark
comedy though it's not straight comedies
dark comedy remember that going in this
is one of those movies where you're
gonna sit there and some messed up stuff
might happen but it's just done so well
that it's so funny thanks a lot for
watching guys and if you liked this
review then you can click right here and
get stuck my eyes
[Music]